- [Jeri] Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
- Hey everyone, I'm Jeri.
- And I'm Gideon.
- And today, our producer has challenges
to turn this Popeyes chicken sandwich
into a sweet dessert.
- Our friend, Tucker, is
gonna come in, try our dishes-
- And then, we're gonna
try to have him guess
what the original dish was.
Are you ready for the challenge Gidsgids?
- Always.
- Let's do it.
(upbeat music)
- So my game plan is I'm gonna turn this
into a maple bacon donut.
First things first, I'm
going to be saving this mayo
for our white chocolate ganache.
Now, I'm going to tear these buns apart.
Now, we're going to toast
these and we're gonna grind it
and turn them into breadcrumbs.
And by toasting these, it
actually intensifies the flavor
of the bread, 'cause it
gets rid of the water
and it's gonna enhance
the flavor of our donut.
All right, now that our
buns are nice and toasted
and it's cooled down,
now we're going to make fine bread crumbs.
(machine whirring)
All right, now this looks perfect
and we're gonna use
this for a donut batter.
- So after seeing the Popeyes sandwich,
I think I'm going to make a
strawberry balsamic cupcake.
So to kick things off,
I'm going to, first, add the sour cream,
some milk and vanilla.
And then, give this a really quick whisk
just to incorporate
all of the ingredients.
And once that's all mixed,
I'm gonna take the bun
and then break it up
into little pieces first.
And then, I'm gonna use a fork to really,
really get it into the wet ingredients.
This is my first time
turning a savory dish
into a sweet dish.
And I'm really curious to
know what Gideon's doing,
but honestly, I'm feeling
pretty confident about this.
And then from here, I'm gonna
move on to my dry ingredients.
- Now, we're going to
make the candied pickles.
The first things first,
we got to rinse it.
All we have to do is mix water, sugar,
and once that's mixed, then
we'll toss the pickles.
So we're just gonna let
this sit until it becomes
like a super light brown,
then we take it out.
These look great,
we're gonna let this set
for about 10 minutes,
so that they harden.
Hopefully, Tucker doesn't
think it's too weird
'cause I wanna win.
- I'm going to mix into my cake flour
some baking soda, baking powder, and salt.
And then from there,
I'm just gonna give
this a really good whisk
just to make sure all
of the dry ingredients
are well incorporated.
Then, I'm going to move
on to creamy my butter
and whip it on high for two minutes
until it's creamy, light, and fluffy.
About now, I'm going to add the sugar,
and then, beat that
for another two minutes
until it's nice
incorporated, super fluffy.
All right, things are
looking good in here.
We're going to add three egg
whites to the sugar mixture.
This is looking so good.
I'm going to add my burger mixture
to these wet ingredients here.
The last step is to add my
dry ingredients to this.
Give it one last mix and we're
good to go with the batter.
This is looking beautiful.
And I'm gonna fill these
just about three quarters of the way up.
I'm going to bake these
until they're nice and puffy
or when a toothpick
inserted comes out clean.
- All right, now, we're
gonna make our dough.
First, we're gonna mix
our wet ingredients,
which is buttermilk, three egg yolks,
one whole egg grape seed
oil, and lemon zest.
And we're gonna whisk it.
Now, for our dry ingredients.
Cake flour, sugar, now the
bread crumbs that we made,
baking powder, baking soda,
salt, cinnamon, and nutmeg.
Now, I'm gonna mix it for a couple seconds
to mix the dry ingredients.
We're gonna slowly add
our wet ingredients.
So we're gonna keep mixing
this until it's well combined.
It's gonna be sticky,
but once it's chilled,
it's gonna gonna be easy to work with.
Now, it's time to roll our dough.
I have this baking sheet
lined with parchment paper.
I'm a little worried 'cause
I'm not that experienced
in making donuts.
You shall see.
Okay, so it's very sticky.
We're going to use
another parchment paper.
So we're gonna roll this
to about half an inch thick
and we're going to chill this
for about 30 to 60 minutes.
Hopefully, it'll be easier to work by then
once it's nicely chilled.
- So for this next part of the cupcake,
I'm going to be taking the fried chicken,
and then create a crispy
chicken buttercream frosting.
Now, I know that sounds super
wacky, but just hold tight.
It's gonna be amazing.
So here, I'm just going
to remove the batter
and try to keep the actual
chicken part intact.
All right, now, look at that, beautiful.
I'm gonna be setting this aside,
and then, transfer this over
to my prepared baking sheet.
And then, I'm going to
just pop this in the oven
just for a little bit
just so I can dry it out
a little bit more to get it super crispy.
So in my next step,
I am going to give this a really good chop
and get the pieces nice and fine.
Listen to that crunch.
You know, Gideon's my boy, he
is the crispy chicken king.
But you know what?
I'm bringing my game.
We're gonna move on to assembling
the rest of the buttercream.
So starting off, I'm going
to, first, cream the butter
and here we have the mayo
from the chicken sandwich,
and that is a lot of mayo.
This is so wacky 'cause
I've never added mayo,
but I'm super excited to
see how it's gonna turn out.
I'm curious to know how
Tucker's going to feel
about having mayo in his
buttercream frosting.
And I don't know if I want to tell him.
I'm going to whip this on medium high
until it's light and creamy and fluffy.
This is looking beautiful.
So we have some vanilla, some heavy cream,
and then, finally, some powdered sugar.
So I'm gonna need about four cups of this
but I'm gonna add it in little batches
just so it doesn't get messy in here.
(machine whirring)
Oh, all right.
Okay, it's looking beautiful.
The last step is adding the
super crispy chicken breading
to the frosting.
I'm just gonna mix this
until the breading is well
incorporated into the frosting.
So this last step is
transferring it to a piping bag,
and then, I'm gonna
set it aside for later.
- Now that our dough has
been nice and chilled,
and it's easy to work with,
we can start cutting them.
I'm gonna sprinkle some flour.
I'm gonna spray the baking
sheet with just some oil.
Now, we have our donut cutter.
We're gonna dip that into the flour.
Oh, there we go, that's nice.
I'm just gonna push it out with
my finger, nice and gently.
We're just gonna let this
chill for 30 minutes,
then we start frying.
About a minute and a half per
side until it's golden brown.
And we're gonna turn them, all right.
Now, I'm just gonna fry up the rest.
- Chicken floss, I'm not gonna lie,
I am taking a huge risk with this.
I've had pork floss,
I've even had fish floss,
but I've never made my own.
So I'm going to rinse
this under warm water
just to remove any excess grease.
So now that I rinse my Popeyes chicken,
I'm gonna add the raw chicken breast
along with the Popeyes chicken together
along with some water and poach it.
So the chicken has been
cooking for about 25 minutes,
it's time to shred it.
So I've transferred the
chicken over to this tray,
but I wanna hold onto
this liquid for later.
The chicken has cooled for a few minutes.
I wonder if Tucker's gonna
be like, what is that, what?
All right, you all,
chicken is fully shredded.
I'm going to add it back
to the reserved liquid
along with some salt and
sugar, and then reduce that.
So I'm cook this on
high heat for 15 minutes
until the pot is completely dried out.
Look at what I've created.
This is straight chicken floss.
Oh, my gosh.
- Okay, now, it's time
to make the ganache.
All we're gonna do is mix heavy cream,
the mayo we saved earlier,
and white chocolate.
We're just gonna mix this
and we're gonna migrate this on high
in 20 to 32nd intervals
until the chocolate's melted.
Now, for the chicken, we're
gonna cut this into thin strips.
We're just gonna toss
maple syrup and brown sugar
until they're coated evenly.
So we're gonna bake this for
about three minutes per side
until it's nice and caramelized
and look like bacon.
- The Popeyes chicken sandwich
has bread and butter pickles.
So what I'm going to do is turn it
into a strawberry jam.
To a sauce pan, I'm going to
add some cut up strawberries.
I chopped up these
bread and butter pickles
from the sandwich, some sugar,
and lastly, balsamic vinegar.
I know you're probably
like, are you serious?
Balsamic vinegar, pickles, strawberries?
Strangely enough, it's
like a happy marriage
of all of these ingredients, I promise.
Next step, I'm going to
make balsamic strawberries.
So I hope Tucker like strawberries
'cause it's like
strawberries on strawberries
on strawberries with fried chicken.
I'm going to add strawberries, sugar,
balsamic vinegar, and lastly, corn syrup.
So I'm gonna mash up the
strawberries just a little bit
and this will really help
release some of the juices.
We're gonna use this immersion blender
and just blend it until it's smooth.
Look at that, just look
at that, it's beautiful.
So I'm gonna let this
cool for about 15 minutes.
My strawberry glaze is completely cooled.
Now, I'm gonna take the raw strawberries,
dip them in the glaze, and
then let them rest here
on this rack just to let any excess glaze
kind of drip to the bottom.
I'm gonna set these to
the side for 30 minutes,
and then, we are ready
to assemble the cupcake.
(upbeat music)
- Now, we have our Popeyes chicken bacon,
candied pickles, mayonnaise
ganache, and burger bun donut.
It's time for assembly.
I'm gonna dip our donut in the ganache.
Now, we're just gonna garnish it
with our chicken bacon
and our candy pickles.
Now here we have it, our
Popeyes chicken sandwich donut.
Now, I'm gonna finish decorating the rest
'cause why should Tucker be
the only one to taste this?
- We have our burger bun cupcakes,
our bread and butter
pickle and strawberry jam,
our chicken floss, our crispy
chicken mayo buttercream,
and last, but certainly not least,
we have our beautiful shiny
strawberry balsamic garnish.
So I'm just gonna give it
just a little, little insert right there.
And then next, I'm going
to get my crispy chicken,
mayo, buttercream.
Look at this, it's just, it's beautiful.
Then, we have these beautiful
balsamic glazed strawberries.
I am most proud of this last step.
Just the tease for Gideon to let him know
that I won this, I won this.
Tucker's gonna choose
this baby right here.
This is for you.
(upbeat music)
- Hmm, this one looks
like it has rope on top.
Is this rope edible?
Okay, and then here we have, oh, my gosh,
a pickle sliced so thinly
I can see through it.
I trust both of these chefs with my life.
So I'm just gonna go really in hard.
Ahh.
Okay, am I getting cream cheese frosting?
Am I getting cream cheese frosting?
This thing is gonna be the
key to me figuring this out.
I don't think I'm mad at it.
I don't think I'd take
a bullet for it either.
We're gonna let that marinate
while I come over to this bad boy.
Mm, oh, my God.
I'm getting like chicken and waffles.
What was that pickle there?
Mm, okay.
- I wonder if Tucker's
gonna be like, what is that?
What?
- What?
They're both breakfast deep.
This is like your classic
waffle with the syrup.
But this one is, you went
to IHOP and you said,
give me that Tooty
Fruity Fresh and Fruity.
Oh, my gosh, this is
really hard, isn't it?
Chefs, please come in.
Hello.
_ Hey.
- What's happening here?
- I'm dying to know who's the winner.
- Okay, this is extremely hard.
(drum rolls)
Oh, and I think I have to go with this one
only because I love that
jerky crunch with this.
I think I'm giving it to Gideon.
What is the dish?
- Before we reveal, one last
guess of the original dish?
- I'm saying fried chicken and waffles.
- Give it to me Gids.
(drumming fingers)
- [Tucker] Hello, a
Popeyes chicken sandwich.
- [Jeri] 100.
- You are lying
to me right now, really?
Never have I ever had one.
A hot dog, I would order
both of your things again.
A hundred percent.
- And that buttercream that you had
was like a crispy chicken
skin and mayonnaise.
- Why did I lap that up like a dog?
- Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
(indistinct)
- Thank you for watching
from Savory Sweet.
- And if there are any savory foods
that you want us to
turn into sweet treats,
let us know in the comments.
- I have one, Crunchwrap Supreme.
- {Jeri] That's good.
- Just an idea.
- Good bye everyone.
Thank you so much.
(bright music)